alright let's answer some audience
questions these are questions that come
in maybe via email maybe via voicemail
or Twitter YouTube Facebook our reddit
discussion forum will take them in all
forms first question is from Carson
saying our votes legitimate or worth
anything if a big portion of the
electorate doesn't vote I'm going to
interpret it as our election results
legitimate I think that's probably what
Carson means here our election results
legitimate or worth anything if a big
portion of the electorate doesn't vote
well if a big portion of the electorate
doesn't vote what you have is a system
in which few people are deciding who are
our elected officials or what ballot
initiatives pass or not so if there
hasn't been rigging of votes if there
hasn't been voter suppression were
people who tried to vote were not able
to either because of uh fabricated and
trumped up and a weird to say trumped up
in the content pun intended yeah but
upon not intended but actually upon uh
unless you have those those specific
instances if a lot of people just never
cared to vote it's still a legitimate
election result it is only worth as much
as saying we have a representative
democracy in which only a small portion
of our electorate of the potential
electorate is actually represented uh I
I don't know that we can say that we
want to go in the direction of mandatory
voting there are countries that have
mandatory voting and in some cases it
works okay in some cases it doesn't and
I actually completely respect the idea
of not voting because you don't feel
that it you vote makes a difference that
in the end it's not going to change
anything I don't agree with it but I
respect that people have the right to do
that now like with jason says often in
national elections he doesn't vote i
would never say that shouldn't be your
right that you should be forced to vote
i would want to convince you that it
actually does make sense to vote and one
of the best pieces of evidence we see is
that from everywhere from presidential
elections all the way down ballot when
voter turnout is unbalanced lower we see
it easier or more more likely that
the more conservative candidate wins so
while yes you can always make the
argument that me individually as a voter
I I as a voter don't make a difference
well yet if you alone didn't vote it
might not change any particular outcome
but the idea that voting doesn't matter
i find to be crazy I think it's
embarrassing that up voter turnouts are
so low yeah so I will say that I have
never voted in a presidential election
yeah I have voted in many local
elections for things that locally I felt
very strongly about yeah but to
elaborate on that it's not that I don't
feel that my vote doesn't count i feel
like it's very important to vote i feel
that the people that feel strongly about
a candidate should vote especially even
if they think they're voting kind of the
whole let's say yankees vs redsox ample
example you voting for the person that
you don't want to win if are voting
against the person don't want to win
makes a big difference I heard
interesting thing riding in this morning
are about cream abdul-jabbar of all
people actually uh in in favor people
not voting saying that if you aren't
actually educated you don't actually
know what these politicians are standing
for you should vote yeah I don't
creative I knew he took that position I
I tend not to agree with that uh I you
know when when someone says look at all
the people having kids that really
should be there should really be a test
for parenting the problem is the
application of that will
disproportionately hurt poor and
minority people and then you're
basically creating a system which is
going to actually further lead to uh
more of one race of kids being bored
than another I think it's very very
dangerous although I completely get I
see people all the time who should not
be having kids the problem is in the
application of a lot of these ideas a
test for voting this is one of the main
things that if you are a citizen you get
to vote and it is out while I completely
understand the concept of we have so
many people who don't even understand
the policies of the candidate they have
maybe have never even heard they're just
voting a party line or they're
completely clueless but believe me I get
it i've spoken to them and we interview
people but voting is a right for
citizens period and you know
unfortunately there are times
you can lose that right including
through the commission of certain crimes
but I think that is very dangerous and I
think some of what Kareem abdul-jabbar
has written is interesting I I couldn't
disagree more with that something else I
found very interesting I heard another
podcast about how people who have
Guardians have to express that they want
to vote in order to vote and this is
coming up in California something like
30,000 people there with guardians and
they were similarly asking should we
test these people did I ask that they
have the comprehensive abilities the you
know the ability to think and understand
right to vote that's that's uh a tough
tough card to play I think it is very
dangerous when we go in that direction
to finalize my answer to the question
yeah elections are legitimate even when
you might have forty percent voter
turnout it just really sucks that more
people are not getting engaged because
it is not truly a representative result